[Music]
after the attack at the capitol building
last week it seemed for a minute
like the rioters who stormed the
building might just get away with it but
some videos emerged online recently of
several of them facing consequences for
their actions and
whenever i see those videos of white
supremacists getting kicked off planes
and
being arrested and stuff it it fills me
up with feelings
word word you know what i'm saying it's
like
ooh the way you make me feel boo
like in that viral video where you're
crying at the airport because you got
put on the no-fly list
for that video where you're getting
pulled off a plane by the cops and the
other passengers
are clapping oh or that video where you
get arrested
in front of your own grandma dang
you got me all up in my feelings yeah i
know it's wrong but
you're suffering
it brings me joy
is it the way you look when you're
getting dragged out of the airport baby
is it the way you reacted
when they said get off the plane
is it the way you scream when you
realize
that you're gonna get it is it the way
you thought that being white was gonna
[Music]
how you make me feel
[Music]
down to my toes i am filled with
joy and a little bit of shape
but mostly so much joy
now normally we'd end the song here and
not double down on the fact that our
hearts are filled with happiness because
other people are feeling anguished but
it's been so long
since we've had any real joy that uh
verse two is it the way
you got arrested at your grandmama's
house
is it the way you screamed they think
that i'm a terrorist
is it the way you think it's okay
to smash up the capitol building
is it the way you think you're innocent
cause you just helped wait for years for
change now it's starting to
[Music]
i'm literally filled with joy it's
[Music]
i am filled with joy
and a little
[Music]
call me crazy girl that's just how i
feel we'll be right back
[Music]
now
you